l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi visant à créer un
ticket restaurant et publiant présentées
par d'autres collègues clair antoine
lévy et plusieurs de ses collègues
demande du groupe union centriste
je vais passer la parole aux orateurs en
prévenant que chacun d'entre vous qui
lie à un petit incident technique qui
fait que seules les caméras qui se
trouve dans mon dos qui se trouve sur le
plateau fonctionne l'incident est en
cours de résolution et ne serait pas
exactement film est comme d'habitude
pour le début de cette séance bien dans
la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur pierre antoine
lévy du groupe union centriste
auteur de la proposition pour dix
minutes monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le président de la commission de la
culture
mes chers collègues je ne cache pas ma
grande satisfaction d'être ici devant
vous aujourd'hui pour l'examen de la
proposition de loi visant à créer un
ticket restaurant étudiants de la
satisfaction oui car c'est ma première
proposition de loi depuis le début de
mon mandat de sénateur et la
satisfaction aussi car sans préjuger de
l'issue du vote qui sera le vôtre
tout à l'heure cette proposition de loi
aura eu de toute façon le mérite de
mettre le doigt sur les inégalités du
système de restauration étudiante dans
notre pays qui pénalise de très nombreux
jeunes mes chers collègues je vais me
permettre de revenir à la génèse de
cette proposition de loi
tout d'abord comme vous comme beaucoup
d'entre vous depuis un an et demi j'ai
été extrêmement sollicités par des
étudiants détresse en tant que premier
adjoint de la ville de montauban dans un
premier temps et depuis octobre dernier
en tant que sénateur
les témoignages de dizaines d'étudiants
dans une situation financière
catastrophique
n'arrivant pour parfois plus à manger
car leur faim le garnissant les files
d'attentes des restos du coeur mans
particulièrement affecté ces images et
ces situations de détresse ne sont pas
tolérables dans notre pays en 2021
nombre de familles notamment celles de
la classe moyenne éprouve les plus
grandes difficultés pour subvenir aux
besoins de leurs enfants dans le cadre
de leurs études
pourtant en france a priori nous n'avons
pas nous plaindre
nous avons une politique d' aides et
accompagnements plutôt efficace les
généreuses les crous qui offrent moors
logement étudiant et restauration
universitaire apporte une réponse plutôt
performante
beaucoup de pays n'ont pas un système
aussi développer cependant vous le savez
bien mes chers collègues souvent les
effets de seuil font qu'un étudiants
issus de la classe moyenne s'entendra
dire désolé monsieur votre situation ne
vous permet pas de bénéficier de telle
ou telle aide
ces étudiants soit disant trop riches
sont au final les villes qui me colle
attirera des critères d'attribution
mais au final pour eux les fins de mois
sont tout aussi difficiles dans d'autres
situations lorsque ce ne sont pas des
effets de seuil
ce ne sont tout simplement les services
des crous qui ne sont pas présents
aucune critique dans mes propos mais
tout simplement un constat les crous ne
peuvent d'ailleurs raisonnablement pas
être présent sur l'ensemble des villes
ou des sites tous ont dispensé des
formations d'enseignement supérieur les
crous font le choix de couvrir en
priorité c'est tout à fait autant
d'appuis ce qu'on appelle campus
universitaire mais l'enseignement
supérieur dans notre pays je ne sont pas
que les universités bien d'autres
acteurs existent les bts les écoles de
commerces les écoles d'ingénieurs les
écoles d'infirmières les classes
préparatoires et bien d'autres encore
dans vos départements vous avez
certainement des formations dispensées
dans des petites communes où loin des
sites universitaires majeur il ya fort à
parier que les crous ne prospecte
propose pas de service de restauration à
ces endroits
petton alors mes chers collègues se
satisfait du fait que des centaines des
milliers d'étudiants ne bénéficie pas
d'un service de restauration car le
crous n'est pas en mesure de leur
proposer
à ce titre le passage du repas dans les
restaurants du crous à 1 euro est une
très bonne chose qui a permis pour de
très nombreux étudiants de préserver
leur pouvoir d'achat
nous ne pouvons que nous en féliciter je
salue cette initiative du gouvernement
pour autant la problématique reste la
même lorsqu'il n'y a pas de restaurants
universitaires dans la commune où l'on
étudie mais également lorsqu'il ne sont
pas ouverts le soir ou le week-end nous
pouvons simplement pas nous satisfaire
de cette situation qui exclut tout en
étudiant de cette aide qui leur est
pourtant dû voilà le sens de cette
proposition de loi mes chers collègues
elle n'est en aucun cas une attaque
contre les crous
comme certains ont voulu le faire croire
avec mauvaise foi cette proposition de
loi permet tout simplement de combler
des trous dans la raquette de l'offre
actuelle des crouch et de combler des
inégalités en pratique comment se
traduit ce ticket restaurant étudiants
il serait inspiré du modèle du ticket
restaurant d entreprise qui a fait ses
preuves depuis des décennies qui
aujourd'hui remettra en cause ces
systèmes qui apporte un véritable gain
de pouvoir d'achat à des millions de
salariés
le ticket restaurant étudiants seraient
achetés 3h30 par l'étudiant c'est le
même prix qu'un repas de restaurant
universitaire en période non qu'ovide
l'état par l'intermédiaire du crous
financera également 3 0 30
de la même façon qu'ils financent
environ la moitié du prix de repas dans
les restaurants universitaires une vraie
question s'est posée savoir s'il fallait
territorialisée la mesure où pas le
rapporteur vous l'expliquera tout à
l'heure mais cela nous a paru être la
meilleure chose afin de limiter l'accès
aux tickets restaurant étudiants
uniquement à ceux ne bénéficiant pas de
restauration universitaire à proximité
je me permets un seul exemple simple de
territorialisation de territorialisation
ici sous nos yeux nos collaborateurs
ceux qui l'exercent au palais ont accès
au restaurant des collaborateurs du 36
rue de vaugirard un tarif préférentiel
leurs collègues en circonscription
bénéficient eux le ticket restaurant car
ils n'ont pas accès au restaurant
d'entreprise
c'est une question d'équité et cela
fonctionne très bien la question du coût
a pu se poser est allé légitime mes
chers collègues car nous sommes tous des
élus responsables mais bien avant de
parler de coût il est important de
parler du devoir moral que je pense que
nous avons envers les étudiants qui
représentent l'avenir de notre pays
beaucoup d'entre eux souffrent de la
précarité bien avant la crise sanitaire
d'autres l'ont découvert depuis un an et
demi il est de notre responsabilité en
tant que responsable politique de leur
apporter des solutions
c'est ce que fait ce texte est ce qu'il
sera suffisant pour régler la
problématique de la précarité étudiante
non mais il y apporte déjà une réponse
sur les coûts mes chers collègues
pouvons nous satisfaire d'une analyse
tronquée en se disant que cela va créer
un surcoût pour les crous assurément non
car si tous les étudiants n'ayant pas
que c'est un restaurant universitaire
pouvait s'y rendre les cruise serait
bien obligé les
accepter pensez vous vraiment que nous
pourrions le répondre désolé mais cela
va coûter cher à l'état ne faisons pas
une économie sur un droit qui n'est tout
simplement pas exercer alors que de très
nombreux étudiants subissent cet état de
fait alors nous avons entendu ici et là
des estimation fantaisiste du coût de
cette mesure 2 milliards d'euros 4
milliards d'euros toujours plus pour
essayer discréditer ce projet je pose
tout simplement la question à ces
organisations qu'avez vous fait pour
régler la situation des étudiants qui ne
bénéficient pas des services du crous
n'étiez-vous pas pourtant majoritaire
pendant toutes ces années ou bien
peut-être que les étudiants en écoles de
commerce les cônes ingénieurs bts ou
classes préparatoires nous intéresse
tout simplement pas de la définition du
coût de cette mesure
je suis de ceux qui pensent que sur
certains sujets nous ne pouvons avoir
une vision seulement comptable
les étudiants ne le comprendraient pas
et je pense qu'ils auraient tout à fait
raison je dis aux responsables des crous
et à vous madame la ministre que
pensez-vous les plus coûteux ouvrir un
restaurant universitaire pour 50 ans
étudiant en bts dans une petite ville où
leur permettent de bénéficier d'un
ticket restaurant étudiants il est
important de se poser cette question
j'espère madame la ministre que ce
projet sera bout c'est dur et retiendra
toute votre attention
comme il a retenu l'attention de plus de
81 sénateurs en dépassant les clivages
politiques
les étudiants ont souffert depuis plus
d'un an et demi est pour beaucoup
il souffre encore de cette précarité
malheureusement lors devant cette
innovation sociale cette équité
car il s'agit bien là d'une innovation
sociale et non d'un gadget ce ticket
restaurant les étudiants se
l'approprieront rapidement avec un grand
sens des responsabilités n'iront pas
s'acheter des sandwiches ou de la junk
food et milliers soir
contrairement aux arguments de nos
détracteurs car il sera tout à fait
possible de manger équilibré avec un
ticket restaurant étudiants
tout comme il est tout à fait possible
de manger déséquilibré dans un
restaurant universitaire arrêtons
d'infantiliser des étudiants ils veulent
bien mieux que cela
alors mes chers collègues pour
l'ensemble des raisons que j'ai évoquées
pour le devoir moral que je pense que
nous avons envers les étudiants qui
n'ont vraiment pas été épargnés depuis
le début de la crise la qu'ovide je vous
invite à une avancée sociale en votant
favorablement à l'issue de nos débats
pour la création d'un ticket restaurant
étudiants j'espère que chez texte s'il
est voté au sénat
sera étudiée rapidement l'assemblée
nationale je remercie à ce propos la
députée anne laure blain qui a déposé la
même proposition de loi similaire
l'assemblée nationale avec qui nous
avons beaucoup échangé je la remercie
d'ailleurs pour sa présence ce matin
je remercie également chaleureusement
mes collègues du groupe de l'union
centriste pour avoir collégialement
sélectionnés ma proposition de loi dans
notre espace réservé ce texte ne doit
pas rester dans un tiroir
il doit permettre au plus vite d'offrir
du pouvoir d'achat aux étudiants
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues je vous remercie pour eux
[Applaudissements]
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est agent hingray rapporteur de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication pour dix minutes
également
j'ai le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
cher laurent mes chers collègues comme
notre collègue pierre antoine lévy vient
de le démontrer avec beaucoup de force
et beaucoup de vigueur sa proposition
loin entend redonner du pouvoir d'achat
sur le plan alimentaire aux étudiants
qui sont durement éprouvée par les
conséquences économiques et sociales de
la crise sanitaire
face à l'aggravation de leur précarité
le gouvernement à baisser le tarif du
ticket resto u à 1 euro d'abord pour les
étudiants boursiers et puis pour tous
les étudiants
cette mesure est bien sûr bénéfique et
nous le saluerons mais constituent-elles
la panacée assurément non premièrement
elle ne fait qu'amplifier la
problématique de l'accès aux structures
de restauration universitaire puisqu'en
sont de facto exclus les étudiants
éloigné des grands campus et des centres
villes nombre d'entre nous avons été
alertés dans nos départements sur cette
inégalité entre les étudiants
deuxièmement le ticket restaurant le
ticket à 1 euro par nom ne constitue pas
un modèle économique viable sur le long
terme sachant que la préparation d'un
repas au restaurant universitaire coûte
de 7 à 8 fois ce tarif troisièmement
cette mesure était conçu pour répondre à
une situation d'urgence
or à ce jour le ministère n'est pas en
mesure de nous dire c'est le va être
prolongée ni même si le périmètre de ses
bénéficiaires est susceptible d'évoluer
il ya toutes les raisons de penser
qu'elles ne constituera pas une solution
pérenne pour notre système de
restauration
c'est donc dans ce contexte pour le
moins incertain que s'inscrit cette
proposition de loin qu'elle en était
l'objectif initial
il s'agissait de permettre à tous les
étudiants quel que soit leur statut
social leur établissement de
rattachement leur situation géographique
le moment de la journée ou de l'année
d'acheter un repas ou de faire des
courses alimentaires
un tarif social cette portée universelle
a suscité des
étude certaines fonder d'autres moins
les prises de position certaines mesures
et d'autres plus caricatural je ne peux
ainsi laissé dire que le but aurait été
de mettre en concurrence le réseau des
oeuvres universitaires avec les acteurs
de la restauration privée
nous savons tous le rôle structurant que
jouent les crous et les efforts
d'adaptation qu'ils ont accompli depuis
une dizaine d'années pour mieux répondre
aux attentes des étudiants
le ticket restaurant ne remet pas cela
en cause il entend élargir l'offre de
restauration et donner davantage de
souplesse aux étudiants qui pourront
choisir d'aller au restaurant us de
manger à l'extérieur ou bien le cuisiner
chez eux
je ne puis non plus laissé dire que la
création n'a tickets restaurant
jetterait les étudiants dans les bras
des fast-foods les infantilise ont pas
ils peuvent parfaitement vouloir faire
leurs courses dans des supérettes pour
consommer des produits que l'on trouve
pas forcément dans la restauration
collective
qui plus est le risque de la malbouffe
peut tout à fait être limitée par des
moyens techniques qui encadrerait
l'utilisation d'un ticket restaurant
dématérialisée en tant que rapporteur
j'ai souhaité dépasser ces clivages et
après avoir entendu toutes les parties
chez une ré c'est un mineur un bilan
bénéfices risques le plus complet
possible à la lumière de celui ci nous
est apparu nécessaire d'ajuster le
dispositif initial en le centrant sur la
problématique de l'accès à la
restauration universitaire qui nous le
voyons bien dans nos territoires
constitue la principale pierre
d'achoppement les 800 points de vente
gérés par les crous ne sont en effet pas
répat répartis de manière homogène
l'existence de zones blanches comme pour
la couverture en réseau de téléphonie
mobile place les étudiants concernés
dans une situation d'inégalité d'accès
au service public de la restauration
universitaire les étudiants territoire
sous dotées en infrastructures sont
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui dans
l'impossibilité de bénéficier du ticket
de resto u à 1 euro c'est pourquoi nous
avons proposé avec pierre antoine lévy à
la commission de cibler le dispositif du
ticket restaurant sur les étudiants qui
sont éloignés des structures
universitaires
ces étudiants pourront ainsi bénéficier
d'un ticket à tarif social pour se
restaurer ou faire des achats
alimentaires
auprès des établissements conventionnés
avec les acteurs territoriaux de l'année
étudiante qu'il s'agisse les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
et crous ou des collectivités
le ciblage de la mesure qui fait du
tarif du ticket restaurant une offre
complémentaire à celle de la
restauration universitaire permet en
outre d'écarter tout risque de
déstabilisation du réseau des oeuvres en
posant le principe d'un ticket restant
étudiants territorialisée la commission
exprime ainsi la nécessité d'offrir à
nos étudiants un enseignement supérieur
de proximité notamment premier cycle qui
ne soit pas cantonné aux grands pôles
universitaires traditionnelle avec des
prestations d'accompagnement qui vont
avec la création d'un ticket restaurant
étudiants réservé aux étudiants isolés
mais très fins et profondes inégalités
territoriales
à l'instar de pays comme l'angleterre ou
la suède celui ce cette solution est
donc une alternative pertinente
techniquement bien accepté par les
principaux acteurs concernés
le gouvernement est donc désormais
prévenus ne peut plus détourner le
regard face à cette jeunesse qui souffre
et qui attend des solutions concrètes et
immédiates pour aller de l'avant
c'est désormais chose faite avec le
ticket restaurant universitaire madame
la ministre monsieur le président je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à madame frédéric vidal mini
de l'enseignement supérieur de la
recherche et de l'innovation
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur mais la médiatrice mais c'est
le sénateur monsieur le sénateur pierre
antoine lévy tout d'abord permettez moi
de saluer l'initiative prise par le
groupe de l'union centriste de nous
permettre de débattre de cette
proposition de loi
dans le premier mérite est d'aborder
clairement la question de la précarité
alimentaire de certains étudiants cet
enjeu n'est pas apparue avec la crise
sanitaire mais force est de constater
que celle-ci l'a rendu plus prégnant que
jamais nous connaissons tous l'engrenage
qui a conduit à cette situation la perte
d emploi étudiant la suspension des
stages rémunérés le soutien familial
parfois par des difficultés
économiques ont fortement entamé les
moyens de subsistance de certains
étudiants ni la communauté universitaire
ni le gouvernement n'ont attendu que les
problématiques de vie étudiante soit un
sujet d'opinion publique pour agir dès
le mois de mars le mets vins les
établissements ont mobilisé le produit
de la contribution vie étudiante et de
campus pour apporter de l'aide à leurs
étudiants y compris de l'aide
alimentaire
de nombreuses initiatives solidaires ont
été lancés par les associations
étudiantes avec le soutien financier du
gouvernement comme la confection de
paniers de repas ou la distribution de
colis alimentaires les liens ont été
resserrés entre les acteurs associatifs
les crous les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur au bénéfice des
étudiants tout en soutenant ces
initiatives et dans le même temps le
gouvernement a déployé un arsenal de
mesures pour faire refluer la précarité
versement des aides exceptionnelles
doublement des aides d'urgence
revalorisation des bourses sur critères
sociaux prolongation du droit à bourse
en fonction des incidences de la crise
sur les cursus réexamen des situations
sociales pour adapter en fonction le
niveau des bourses
j'ai des frais d'inscription gel des
loyers des logements des cros création
de 20000 emplois étudiants mise en place
de distributeurs de protection période
est gratuite voici quelques-unes des
actions qui ont été menées et
l'instauration du ticket de restauration
1 euros pour les boursiers à la rentrée
puis étendu en janvier à tous les
étudiants boursiers non-boursiers
étudiants internationaux pour deux repas
par jour emblématique de cet engagement
gouvernemental pour la jeunesse il est
tout aussi emblématique de la
mobilisation des crous et de leurs
personnels et que je veux ici remercier
infiniment pour leur engagement sans
faille
ils ont fait preuve d'une réactivité
d'une adaptation remarquable pour
assurer le déploiement effectif de la
mesure pour proposer de nouveaux
services comme la vente à emporter la
livraison le click and collect pour
rouvrir le restaurant aux étudiants en
respectant des protocoles sanitaires
parfois très exigeant il faut se rendre
compte de ce que cela veut dire de
mettre en oeuvre en un week end un
ticket ru à 1 euro pour tous les
étudiants de déplacer les structures
mobiles en en bas des cités
universitaires de changer en profondeur
la chaîne de production pour délivrer
les plats à emporter
c'est tout à l'honneur de ce service
public qui a été au rendez-vous de cette
crise et à ce jour c'est plus de 10
millions de repas un euro qui ont été
servis ce qui est inédit
aucun autre pays européen ne s'est
engagé à ce point au service de ses
étudiants mais bien sûr il reste encore
beaucoup à faire et à l'heure où la vie
revient partout sur notre territoire il
est plus que jamais nécessaire de tirer
toutes les leçons de l'année écoulée de
les tirer collectivement pour améliorer
durablement les conditions de vie
étudiantes qui sont consubstantiels à la
réussite académique et finalement à
l'émancipation de chacune et de chacun
au ministère le porte depuis le début de
ce quinquennat mais cette crise a permis
à de nombreux acteurs de considérer
l'étudiant à globalité
cette approche globale du jeune d'un
parcours étudiant coordonnées sont bien
les maîtres mots de la politique
d'accompagnement que nous menons à
chaque instant nous devons considérer
l'étudiant comme un jeune adulte
les actions de soutien aux étudiants met
en oeuvre que ce soit par le
gouvernement
les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur les crous les collectivités
territoriales ou par le tissu associatif
témoigne que la vie étudiante n'est pas
un supplément d'âme le bien-être
étudiants est un objet politique de
premier plan au coeur de l'action de son
ministre c'est pourquoi je salue
l'initiative du sénat qui a su s'emparer
depuis quelques mois de la question de
la précarité étudiante à travers la
proposition de loi dont nous débattons
ce matin mais également par la mission
d'information sénatoriale sur les
conditions de vie étudiante qui mène ses
travaux depuis plus de six mois et qui
j'en suis convaincue nourrira utilement
les réflexions que nous menons sur ce
sujet c'est bien cette démarche globale
qui envisage la vie étudiante sous
l'ensemble de ses facettes
avant pendant comme ap la crise
sanitaire que nous devons mener ensemble
par la proposition de loi que nous
examinons ce matin vous avez souhaité je
crois répondre à un double enjeu
le premier c'est celui de l'adaptation
de la restauration à la vie étudiante
nous partageons tous ici la conviction
que ce dont nos étudiants aujourd'hui
besoin c'est une alimentation de qualité
dans un cadre en phase avec leurs
habitudes leurs contraintes et leurs
aspirations en forme une offre de
restauration gage de santé de bien-être
de réussite et cette approche globale
c'est précisément celles qui est porté
par les crous qui ont fait des efforts
considérables ces dernières années pour
moderniser et adapter diversifier leur
offre les étudiants ne s'y sont pas
trompés ils sont 81% à la plébisciter et
avant la crise l'activité des
restaurants universitaires augmenté en
moyenne de 5% chaque année aujourd'hui
manger dans un restaurant universitaire
ça signifie avoir accès à un repas
complet et équilibré confectionnés avec
des produits de qualité dans une
démarche de développement durable
c'est avoir le choix entre des menus
végétariens
une cuisine plus traditionnelle le choix
entre sa table et où manger plus
rapidement c'est surtout retrouver ce
lien social qui a fait si cruellement
défaut à nos étudiants cette année
autrement dit l'offre des crous va bien
au-delà de la simple restauration pour
se prolonger en un véritable
accompagnement social en haut lieu
faiseurs de liens qui constitue à part
entière un facteur de réussite dans le
parcours de formation je sais vous
l'avez rappelé que vous reconnaissez
pleinement la valeur ajoutée des crous
et que vous êtes soucieux de ne pas
déséquilibrer un service public de
qualité qui mobilise des agents tous
très investis mais le véritable enjeu
c'est un point qui est revenu lors de
l'examen du texte en commission c'est
bien celui de l'égalité d'accès à une
restauration universitaire avec plus de
750 implantations réparties dans 220
terrine gilles les crous my déjà
l'essentiel du territoire
sur les 2,8 millions d'étudiants
accueillis dans l'enseignement supérieur
2030 au moins un restaurant
universitaire dans leur environnement
immédiat et la restauration
universitaire n'est pas le privilège que
des grands sites universitaires dont 190
sites supplémentaires
le réseau des heures à construire des
partenariats avec les collectivités les
associations pour apporter une offre de
restauration dédié aux étudiants c'est
considérable
et pourtant il est nécessaire d'en faire
plus car comme vous le soulignez il
subsiste encore des zones blanches
notamment dans certains territoires
isolés ne négligeons pas non plus la
question de la pression étudiante dans
certaines grandes villes ou dans
certaines régions ou bien qu'il y ait
des restaurants universitaires et bien
la pression des étudiants peut aussi
parfois générer des problèmes
je tiens à être tout à fait clair
s'agissant de la position du
gouvernement
cette proposition de loi pose des
questions centrales et je travaille je
salue le travail réalisé par la
commission et le rapporteur la
commission a souhaité mieux cibler le
dispositif
mais il nous faut poursuivre ce travail
pour parvenir à construire une solution
globale aux disparités territoriales
très justement pointé par votre
proposition de loi monsieur le sénateur
léger pour gober ces disparités sont
pour autant renoncer à la garantie d'une
restauration de qualité je crois qu'il
nous faut mobiliser tous les leviers
disponibles en fonction des réalités
locales avec pour boussole la nécessité
de construire une offre accessible de
repas équilibrés ouverte à l'ensemble
des étudiants quel que soit leur lieu
d'études
en l'état je ne suis pas convaincu que
le ticket restaurant étudiants soit à
lui seul une réponse suffisante mais il
doit pouvoir s'inscrire comme un outil
envisageable dans le cadre d'une
solution plus globale
lorsqu'il n'est pas possible de
construire une offre sociale à assumer
directement par l'état ou assuré avec le
soutien des collectivités des
associations
en premier lieu il n'existe pas à ce
jour d'offres de titres de paiement
réglementé permettant d'ajouter au
forfait de 6 euros 60
le complément indispensable pour
s'offrir un repas complet et équilibré
peut-être cela sera-t-il possible si les
entreprises se positionnent clairement
mais il faudra du temps pour cela
par ailleurs bien que le dispositif tel
tissu de la commission permettent déjà
de mieux cibler la mesure son cours
resteraient conséquent sans pour autant
garantir l'équité sociale entre les
étudiants pouvant s'offrir un repas
complet au delà du forfait et ceux qui
ne peuvent pas se le permettre
pour moi la réponse s'écrire
prioritairement à travers les
partenariats construits localement avec
les collectivités
elle est dans des dispositifs qui
existent déjà qui ont fait leurs preuves
dans des zones dépourvues de restaurants
universitaires les crous ont mis en
place des politiques d'agrément et de
conventionnement qui permettent aux
étudiants de bénéficier des structures
de restauration comme les cantines
administrative scolaire ou hospitalières
soumises aux mêmes exigences de qualité
de service public
accompagnons donc ce développement
dieccte draguignan guéret mende morlaix
saint lô viennent sont des villes pour
lesquelles le clou j'ai l'ensemble des
crocs
on commence et où sont prêts à engager
les discussions avec les collectivités
pour trouver des solutions concrètes à
l'horizon des prochains mois avant la
rentrée 2022 nous pouvons réussir à
répondre aux attentes de l'ensemble des
territoires qui sont encore trop éloigné
de la restauration universitaire et je
suis prête à m'engager avec vous en
novembre dernier vous avez adopté à
l'initiative de la sénatrice laure
darcos le principe dans le cadre de la
loi de programmation de la recherche
d'une contractualisation entre les sites
universitaires et les collectivités qui
d'ores et déjà associés les crous en
engageant cette nouvelle vague de
contractualisation paraîtront aux
acteurs territoriaux de répondre à
l'exigence d'équité territoriale comme
je voulais rappeler ces partenariats
permettent aujourd'hui d'apporter des
solutions dans près de 180 dix sites
universitaires isolé à ce jour près
d'une quinzaine relève encore de ces
zones blanches mais je suis convaincu
que nous disposons déjà des leviers
permettant de répondre à leurs attentes
pour faciliter cette démarche il
pourrait être utile de déverrouiller au
bénéfice des collectivités des
associations
l'accès de ses partenaires à la centrale
d'achat national du cnous qui est la clé
de l'offre de produits alimentaires à la
fois qualitative et à tarif attractif
des restaurants universitaires et par
tout cela est nécessaire nous le ferons
bien évidemment j'ajoute que ce sujet
demande un grand effort de concertation
avec les organisations représentatives
des étudiants dont les deux principales
la fage et l'unef ont pris position
clairement mais je ne doute pas qu'il
sera possible de trouver un point
d'équilibré à travers la définition d'un
objectif de couverture complète de
l'ensemble des sites universitaires en
renforçant les outils dont nous
disposons déjà à cette fin ce que nous
visons
au fond ce n'est pas seulement que nous
étudions mangent à leur faim c'est qu'il
gagne en autonomie on pouvoir d'agir et
ce que nous voulons leur offrir ce n'est
pas seulement un quotidien dit
mais bien des conditions de vie
favorables à leur réussite et leur
émancipation
c'est pourquoi cette question de la
lutte contre la précarité alimentaire
doit être intégrée dans une vision
globale l'accompagnement social des
étudiants est articulée à la réforme des
bourses sur critères sociaux sur
laquelle nous sommes en train de
travailler
la précarité étudiante est l'un des
grands défis des mois à venir elle est
aussi une opportunité de changer notre
regard sur les étudiants pour penser
enfin la singularité de ce statut j'ai
toute confiance dans notre capacité à la
saisir ensemble
à cet égard nous aurons l'occasion de
prolonger le débat en examinant les
amendements déposés sur ce texte
toujours est il que le travail reste
encore devant nous tant parce que le
présent texte est encore perfectible et
que nous disposons d'ores et déjà des
outils permettant de couvrir les
dernières zones blanches de notre
territoire à l'horizon des prochains
mois je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre dans la suite
de la discussion générale
la parole est à notre collègue bernard
fialaire pour le groupe rdse pour 4
minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président de la commission et mes chers
collègues la crise sanitaire a
profondément aggraver la précarité
étudiante troubles psychologiques perte
de revenu d'appoint décrochage scolaire
c'était à les conséquences sont
nombreuses et jette les étudiants dans
ces situations matérielles difficiles
le gouvernement a introduit l'été
dernier une mesure essentielle dans
l'accompagnement des étudiants mét en
oeuvre des repas un euro dans les
restaurants universitaires pour les
étudiants boursiers d'abord cependant
les auteurs de la proposition de loi
dont mes collègues du groupe rdse
véronique guillotin et andré guiol sont
cosignataires soulève à juste titre que
cette décision s'avère à usage immédiat
lithaire en effet elle exclut de fait
les étudiants boursiers éloigné des
grands campus et des centres villes et
donc du système de restauration crous
pour autant si les auteurs du texte
prévoyait un ticket restaurant étudiants
disponibles à tout moment pour tous les
étudiants
cette situation était peut-être mal
adapté et un peu trop large
en effet avec cette mesure les crous
aurait dû faire face à la concurrence de
la restauration privée avec finalement
moindre financement
en outre l'objectif de lutte contre la
précarité étudiante ne sera pas
facilement atteints par ce dispositif
en effet il est difficile de trouver un
repas complet et équilibré pour 6 euros
la commission a utilement procéder à des
modifications du texte pour centrer la
proposition de loi sur la problématique
de l'accès à la restauration
universitaire en effet en l'absence
d'une répartition homogène des
restaurants universitaires l'existence
de zones blanches en la matière place
certains étudiants en situation
d'inégalité d'accès aux services publics
du secousse ces étudiants des ces
territoires sous dotées en
infrastructures sont ainsi dans
l'impossibilité de bénéficier des tarifs
sociaux la commission
ainsi resserré le dispositif dont le
coût budgétaire initial évalué entre 2
et 3 milliards d'euros annuels rendait
insoutenable la proposition désormais le
ticket sera territorialisée est proposée
aux seuls étudiants éloignés des
structures de restauration universitaire
ceux ci pourront bénéficier d'un ticket
à tarif social pour se restaurer ou
faire des achats alimentaires auprès
d'établissements des établissements
conventionnés dont d'ailleurs nous
souhaiterions connaître les modalités de
conventionnement ce ticket restaurant
étudiants sera ainsi une offre
complémentaire à celle de la
restauration universitaire cette
solution permet d'ailleurs d'écarter
tout risque de déstabilisation de la
situation financière déjà très délicate
du crous
dans le même temps elle créera un cercle
vertueux avec les acteurs locaux de la
restauration qui en auront
particulièrement besoin au moment de
cette reprise d'activité
le groupe rdse comme je les dis est
favorable à cette innovation qui ira
dans le sens d'un meilleur service aux
étudiants et par conséquent nous
voterons ce texte avec enthousiasme pour
autant il sera nécessaire d'aller plus
loin à l'occasion de l'examen du projet
de loi de finances en pérennisant le
repas à 1 euro qui constitue une mesure
sociale fondamentale à destination des
étudiants précaires
il faudra alors trouver de nouvelles
sources de financement sauf à
déséquilibrer totalement les budgets et
les capacités d'investissement des crous
or cette situation risque d'affecter
toutes les autres missions des crous le
logement l'accompagnement social l'accès
à la santé ou à la culture
autant de secteurs prioritaires pour les
conditions de la vie étudiante
merci chers collègues la parole est
désormais à pierrot zulia ce pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste catherine monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je partage l'émotion
collective qui s'est manifestée dans cet
hémicycle un grand pays comme le nôtre
ne peut accepter qu'une partie de sa
jeunesse sa jeunesse estudiantine
souffrent de la faim et soit contrainte
de trouver sa pitance auprès des
associations caritatives
cette crise n'est pas seulement la
conséquence d'une situation qui a privé
les étudiants d'une partie de leurs
ressources
elle est le symptôme aggravée par la
pandémie d'une augmentation continue et
ancien de la précarité étudiante
le sénat a souhaité en analyser
précisément les causes et les
conséquences dans le cadre d'une mission
d'information dont vous m'avez fait
l'honneur chers collègues de me confier
la présidence et je vous en remercie
ces images des longues files d'attentes
des étudiants devant les soupes
populaires ne doivent pas faire oublier
la mobilisation absolument
extraordinaire du réseau des centres
régionaux des oeuvres universitaires et
scolaires les croches nous devons saluer
collectivement l'extrême mobilisation de
tout leur argent qu'ils ont su dans des
circonstances très difficiles
adapter en permanence à des normes
sanitaires très changeante leurs
services pour offrir aux étudiants dans
les restaurants universitaires des repas
un accueil et un peu de chaleur humaine
l'action des crous dans les résidences
universitaires a été aussi d'un grand
secours et a certainement permis
d'éviter de nombreux drames
l'abaissement du tarif du repas à l'euro
symbolique pour les boursiers puis dans
un deuxième temps pour l'ensemble des
étudiants fut une mesure de salubrité et
d'humanité absolument nécessaire elle
doit être pérennisé aussi madame la
ministre vous
pouvez nous donner ces ans l'assurance
que la charge budgétaire supplémentaire
imposée au réseau des crous sera
compensée dans la loi de finances
rectificative qui sera soumise au
parlement prochainement et que le coût
de la prolongation de cette mesure sera
intégrée dans le budget pour l'année
néanmoins il est incontestable que le
réseau des crous malgré ses 400
restaurants ne peut apporter une offre
de restauration à tous les étudiants sur
l'ensemble du territoire
pratiquement il n'est pas raisonnable de
demander la création de restaurants dans
des communes où la densité d'étudiants
est trop faible pour assurer ce service
je pense par exemple aux 175 étudiants
de l'antenne universitaire de
l'université de perpignan à mende en
lozère en l'occurrence il serait
nécessaire que le crous puisse passer
une convention avec une collectivité
pour permettre à ses 175 étudiants
d'accéder à la restauration collective
disponible à mende
c'est à ces deux conditions absence
d'une offre du crous et accès des
étudiants la restauration collective des
organismes publics que nous considérons
que cette proposition est susceptible de
contribuer à l'extension du service
public de la restauration universitaire
avec l'aide des collectivités la crise
pandémique a montré que l'action
coordonnée des crous et des
collectivités était essentiel pour
renforcer les services offerts aux
étudiants
il faut que vous donniez madame la
ministre au réseau des crous les moyens
budgétaires d'un développement de sa
politique d'agrément avec les
collectivités et les organismes publics
pour qu'ils puissent assurer le service
public de la restauration universitaire
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
pour reprendre mon exemple madame la
ministre
il n'appartient qu'à vous que les 175
étudiants demandent puissent accéder à
un service de rations de restauration
collective d'un organisme public dès la
rentrée prochaine et je crois que sur ce
point vous
avait donné un accord favorable et je
vous en remercie merci monsieur le
président merci chers collègues la
parole et à notre collègue sabine von
règles pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste avait été notée
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président de commission mais sur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues je veux
remercier nos collègues du groupe de
l'union centriste de nous proposer
l'examen de cette proposition de loi
visant à créer un ticket restaurant
étudiants et salué la qualité du travail
de notre rapporteur
au départ je dirais que j'ai accueilli
plutôt favorablement la perspective
posés par cette proposition de loi
en effet les étudiants n'ont pas tous
accès à la restauration universitaire
cette proposition de loi peut donc
paraître frappé du coin du bon sens car
l'utilisation d'un ticket resto est
simple souple et peu semblait
correspondre aux habitudes des jeunes
cependant plus nous avons travaillé le
sujet - nous avons été convaincus et les
travaux menés en commission la semaine
dernière ont encore à fait remis notre
conviction sur le sujet beaucoup
d'étudiants par la voix de leur
représentant s'oppose à cette ppl
invoquant même l'expression que je peux
faire mienne de fausse bonne idée même
si les questions budgétaires sont très
peu évoqué dans cette proposition de loi
l'instauration de ces titres restaurant
représenterait un investissement
conséquent dépassant le milliard d'euros
par an où va aller l'argent ainsi
investi c'est très flou dans la ppl mais
il est à craindre que ce soit dans les
enseignes de restauration rapide et
s'agit donc manifestement d'un soutien
au secteur privé autant sinon plus que
d'une aide aux étudiants conduisant à
terme un affaiblissement du service
public d prou ce qui pénaliserait les
étudiantes et les étudiants les plus
précaires quitte à faire un
investissement conséquent direction des
étudiants pourquoi ne pas les aider
directement par une par une aide
financière qu'il réclame d'ailleurs à
hauteur de 1,5 milliard d'euros et qui
permettrait de lutter plus efficacement
contre la pauvreté étudiants qui
s'accroît je rappelle que les sénatrices
et sénateurs du groupe socialistes
écologistes et républicains sont
favorables à l'extension du rsa jeunes
aux 18 25 ans en particulier en ces
périodes très difficiles de crise
sanitaire les tickets restaurant peuvent
également être le vecteur d'une certaine
malbouffe
la solution étant d'avoir recours à la
restauration rapide et ses qualités
nutritionnelles souvent discutable
la proposition de loi que nous examinons
ce matin fait aussi l'impasse sur les
enjeux budgétaires renvoyant presque
tous au pouvoir réglementaire mais dans
l'exposé des motifs il est fait
référence est une valeur du ticket resto
de 6 euros 60 avec une prise en charge
pour les étudiants de 3 euros 30 qui est
de l'état ou des collectivités
territoriales prendra en charge le
complément
c'est le grand flou un flou qui peut
faire craindre aux collectivités
territoriales un nouvel alourdissement
de leurs charges
3h30 à la charge des étudiants c'est
beaucoup et les plus précaires d'entre
eux ne pourront pas prendre en charge
cette somme
pourquoi père est-il 3 euros 30 alors
même que le ticket resto u est
actuellement à 1 euro sauf à présupposer
que cette mesure bienvenue s'arrête
or c'est une mesure qu'il faudrait au
contraire aider à être pérennisées
durant quand de très longs mois les
étudiants vont subir de plein fouet les
conséquences économiques de cette crise
sanitaire sans précédent en termes de
logement ou encore d'emploi étudiants
leurs difficultés ne se limite
malheureusement pas la nourriture elles
sont protéiformes et nécessitent je le
répète une aide financière directe
je crains que l'éventuelle création de
tickets restaurant étudiants
n'affaiblisse au bénéfice du privé les
restaurants universitaires dont la
mission n'est pas seulement de nourrir
les étudiants plutôt bien d'ailleurs de
manière équilibrée
ils ont aussi une importante mission de
socialisation de repérage des élèves en
difficulté ou en décrochage la
restauration représente environ 30% du
chiffre d'affaires des crous les priver
d'une part de cette activité risque de
mettre à mal leur autre mission logement
s social culture je veux rappeler que la
dotation budgétaire annuel des crous on
s'élève à seulement 10% du coût
prévisionnel de la création des tickets
restaurants pour les étudiants 367
millions d'euros pour 2021 hors crédits
supplémentaires du plan de relance pour
compenser la baisse à 1 euro du ticket
resto u
le risque de fermeture de site de
licenciement de personnel et de baisses
de prestations est donc très important
cette proposition de loi met en avant
des solutions inspirées par l'ultra
libéralisme économique
l'individu
alice le repli sur la sphère privée
l'alternative consisterait à augmenter
les moyens du réseau des oeuvres
permettant de multiplier les conventions
les partenariats avec les collectivités
pour généraliser à terme l'accès à la
restauration à tous les étudiants sur
tous les territoires
les modifications apportées par notre
rapporteur en commission la semaine
dernière ne nous rassurent
malheureusement pas la restriction
bénéfice du dispositif aux seuls
étudiants éloigné des restaurants
universitaires introduit un critère
uniquement géographique et non social et
n'apportent pas davantage de garanties
sur les financeurs les conditions
d'entrée dans le dispositif et le tarif
des tickets ces nouvelles dispositions
diminue certes le coût de la mesure mais
les risques perdurent d'une prise en
charge par des financements publics
d'une alternative privé non accessible à
tous au détriment du service public de
restauration universitaire et au risque
d'un manque à gagner pour celui ci pour
toutes les raisons que je viens
d'évoquer notamment le flou qui résident
dans la rédaction de cette proposition
de loi
les sénatrices et sénateurs socialistes
écologistes et républicains s'y
opposeront je vous remercie
[Musique]
merci chers collègues
donc je passe maintenant la parole à
céline boulay sp rognés pour le groupe
l'est républicain
c'est président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
aujourd'hui et alors nous espérons
pouvoir sortir de la crise sanitaire à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés depuis
des mois personne n'ignore plus les
difficultés économiques et la précarité
à laquelle sont confrontés les étudiants
au travers de nos auditions dans le
cadre de la mission d'information sur
les conditions de vie étudiante
nous avons constaté combien la crise
sanitaire a servi de loupe sur les
difficultés économiques strict sur
structurelles liées au monde étudiant
d'après les données de l'observatoire de
la vie étudiante durant le premier
confinement 56 % des étudiants ont
souffert de difficultés dans la gestion
de leurs dépenses alimentaires
plus inquiétant encore
car d'entre eux n'ont pas été en mesure
de manger à leur faim contre seulement
6% avant la pandémie
les files d'attentes qui s'allongent
devant les épiceries sociales et
solidaires des campus témoigne de l'
aggravation dramatique de la précarité
alimentaire et au delà de cette
difficulté se pose celle de l'adaptation
de l'offre alimentaire à la vie
étudiante
face à cette situation d'urgence la
création d'un ticket restaurant que
propose monsieur lévy est une solution
bienvenue pour les étudiants privés d'un
accès à la restauration universitaire et
je salue le rapporteur du texte monsieur
un regret pour son travail fourni certes
le ticket de resto u 1 euro est une
initiative louable qui a permis de faire
face à l'urgence de la crise mais ce
dispositif n'est pas viable sur le plan
budgétaire et n'a pas vocation à être
pérennisées
de plus il ne résout pas le problème de
l'inégalité territoriale dans l'accès
aux restaurants universitaires
al'inverse des tickets restaurant
étudiants présentent l'avantagé
d'élargir le cadre géographique de la
restauration étudiante aux territoires
les plus reculés
toutefois le ticket restaurant étudiants
ne doit pas avoir pour conséquence de
précipiter ces bénéficiaires vers le
mode de restauration rapide au détriment
de leur santé va de soi de la même
manière il ne faut pas négliger la
difficulté en termes d' avance de
trésorerie qu'induirait la délivrance de
tickets restaurant par l'eau des
étudiants qu'ils sont souvent pas en
mesure d'avancer une somme conséquente
nul coup difficilement soutenable du
dispositif initial évalué entre 2 et 3
milliards d'euros
enfin il ne saurait s'agir agir de
mettre en concurrence les crous avec les
opérateurs privés lieu de vie
emblématique de la vie estudiantine ces
derniers rivalisent d'efforts depuis de
nombreuses années pour adapter leur
offre à l'évolution des besoins
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
soutiens pleinement l'amendement proposé
par monsieur le rapporteur est adoptée
en commission qui circonscrit dispositif
du ticket restaurant aux étudiants trop
éloignés des structures de restauration
universitaire plus cohérente sur le plan
budgétaire cette modification permet de
réaffirmer le caractère complémentaire
de la mesure et de répondre au problème
des zones
sans pour autant déstabiliser
l'écosystème des oeuvres universitaires
et scolaires
avant de conclure je souhaiterais salué
le formidable travail accompli par de
nombreuses associations d aide
alimentaire durant la crise sanitaire
qu'il s'agisse des restos du coeur de
linky ou d'autres dont les bénévoles ont
distribué plus de 40000 panier repas
gratuits aux étudiants franciliens
depuis le mois d'octobre dernier
ces acteurs représente un soutien de
taille de grande taille à l'heure de
voler au secours des plus démunis
en adoptant cette position loi le sénat
prouvera que leurs efforts n'ont pas été
vains et que la représentation nationale
a pris la mesure des difficultés
rencontrées par une partie de la
jeunesse de france je vous remercie bien
merci chers collègues la parole et à
vanina paoli paoli agen pour le groupe
les indépendants
merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
la proposition jacques nous examinons
aujourd'hui vise à créer un ticket
restaurant étudiants valable dans les
restaurants et supermarchés
conventionnés d'une valeur de 6 à 7
euros ces titres seraient financés par
l'état avec un reste à charge pour
l'étudiant de 3h30 ce dispositif
permettrait de réduire les dépenses
alimentaires des étudiants et de lutter
dans le contre la précarité des jeunes
particulièrement touchés par la crise
sanitaire
en effet vous l'avais dit la disparition
d'un grand nombre d'emplois étudiants de
contrats d'intérim et l'annulation de
nombreux stages rémunérés en plongée des
milliers d'étudiants dans une situation
de grande fragilité financière
un dispositif similaire mais temporaire
a été mis en place à l'initiative que
nous avons salué du ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur dans le cadre
d'un programme d'aidé d'urgence
en complément des repas un euro dans les
restos et je partage pleinement les
objectifs de cette proposition de loi
c'est la raison pour laquelle je l'avais
personnellement cosigné toutefois ce
dispositif initial appelle un certain
nombre de réserves
tout d'abord l'absence de ciblage du
dispositif risque de concurrencer les
restaurants universitaires et de
fragiliser le modèle économique des
crous dont rappelons le 30 % des
ressources repose sur la restauration
par ailleurs la distribution de tickets
restaurant à l'ensemble de la population
étudiante coûterait vous l'avez déjà
citée pas moins de 3 milliards d'euros à
l'état pour ces raisons la commission de
la culture a fait le choix de cibler le
dispositif sur les étudiants situés en
zone blanche et n'ayant pas accès aux
restaurants universitaires qui propose
le repas équilibrés deux fois par jour à
1 euro j'adhère pleinement à cet
ajustement au delà de la réponse
apportée à la précarité alimentaire des
étudiants cette proposition va pose la
question du maillage territorial des
établissements supérieurs
et de l'égalité d'accès de nos étudiants
aux dispositifs d'accompagnement en
effet l'enseignement supérieur ne
comporte pas que des universités mais
aussi des établissements de proximité
qui peuvent être éloignés des grands
centres urbains la décentralisation des
études supérieures nécessite une
décentralisation des prestations
d'accompagnement dont l'accès à
l'alimentation est une composante
évidemment essentiel le ticket
restaurant de proximité est une réponse
adaptée aux besoins de ses étudiants il
s'agit pas de concurrencer les repas 1
euros proposés par les crous mais juste
de compléter ce dispositif précisément
dans ces zones reculées
d'où le crous est absente cette mesure
s'inscrit pleinement dans le bouquet
d'actions menées par le gouvernement
bien en amont de la crise pour améliorer
les conditions de vie de nos étudiants
je pense à la suppression de la
cotisation de sécurité sociale depuis
2018 à l'augmentation des bourses sur
critères sociaux
l'inversement anticipé depuis 2020 et le
plan de construction de 60 mille
logements étudiants supplémentaires
d'ici 2022
nous soutenons ces actions
indispensables et skeleton que le
gouvernement s'engage encore davantage
pour permettre à l'ensemble de nos
étudiants quel que soit leur lieu
d'étude de bénéficier des meilleures
conditions de vie possible aussi le
groupe les indépendants république et
territoires votre à cette proposition
devra je vous remercie bien merci la
parole est maintenant à monique
démarquons pour le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mais sa collègue
la précarité étudiante ne fait que
s'aggraver depuis des années le coût des
études augmente et le logement
représente les deux tiers du budget 6
36% des étudiants en touchent et les
bosses en 2019 2020
celle-ci ne permettent souvent pas de
vivre sans travailler à côté
or le cumul entre études et emploi est
la première cause d'échec à l'université
au sortir de la crise sanitaire le
conseil d'état plus frappant la
situation économique des étudiants s'est
dégradée selon un sondage de la
fondation abbé pierre
20% des jeunes ont eu recours à l'aide
alimentaire en 2020 la moitié des
étudiants ont également apporté des
difficultés à payer leurs repas et leur
loyer aussi je ne peux que saluer
l'intention de notre collègue et auteurs
de cette proposition de loi monsieur
lévy qui a naturellement voulu répondre
aux difficultés alimentaires et d'accès
à une structure de restauration
collective
mais cette proposition de loi ne semble
une fausse bonne idée et elle n'est pas
à la hauteur des attentes des étudiants
tout d'abord cela qualité de
l'alimentation
le montant du ticket trop faible pour
garantir l'accès à une restauration
équilibrée avec des produits de qualité
nous courons ainsi le risque de
favoriser les chaînes de restauration
rapide qui ne sont saines
ni pour notre santé ni pour notre
environnement il est primordial de
proposer une solution en accord avec des
besoins et des attentes des étudiants
d'autant plus qu'une enquête de
satisfaction du cnous menée en 2019 a
fait ressortir que 59% d'entre eux s'y
rendent pour avoir accès à un repas sain
équilibré les crous font des efforts
considérables pour proposer une
alimentation variée équilibrée
ils se sont engagés à renforcer l'offre
bio et végétarienne par ailleurs les
missions du crous ne se limite pas à
distribuer des repas
ce sont des lieux de sociabilité et des
changes qui permet aussi d'identifier
des étudiants les plus fragiles et de
les accompagner tout au long de leurs
études
avec cette mesure
l'état devra effectuer des dépenses
publiques pour permettre aux étudiants
de consommer dans le privé sans les
avantages l'accompagnement des talismans
du crous pourrait garantir dans sa
première mouture cette proposition de
loi mettait en danger le fonctionnement
des restaurants universitaires et par
extension des crous monsieur le
rapporteur lors des auditions vous avez
entendu des critiques des syndicats
étudiants et du crous de ce fait vous
avez limiter le champ de cette mesure
aux zones blanches mais cela ne règle
pas tous les problèmes que risque
d'engendrer ces tickets de restaurant et
que je viens d'évoquer d'autres
solutions sont possibles comme déployer
le réseau des restaurants universitaires
dans les zones blanches élargir les
horaires en soirées et week-ends et
permettre au crous de renforcer de
conclure des partenariats avec des
collectivités associations par exemple
des lycées les hôpitaux et même des
ehpad ou encore pérenniser leurs pains
euros cette mesure rapide efficace qui a
permis de limiter la sécurité
alimentaire pendant la crise du colis de
19 mai encore il existe une mesure
simple pour ig en partie les difficultés
financières et les inégalités entre
étudiants cette mesure c'est de revenu
universel d'autonomie pour tous les
jeunes qui avait évoqué en 2019 par le
gouvernement malheureusement c'est
encore un espoir d'avancer social que ce
gouvernement aura déçu vous l'aurez
compris et pour toutes ces raisons que
j'ai évoquées le groupe écologie
solidarité territoire vote raconte cette
proposition de loi
je vous remercie bien merci je vais
passer la parole à julien bargeton pour
le groupe air des pays en signalant que
caméra de secours est rétabli et donc il
ya à nouveau une vision de face pour
retransmettre nono débat non non ça
avait commencé avec monsieur avec madame
monique de marco
j'ai fait il prendre pour moi monsieur
le président donc nous sommes réunis
pour examiner une proposition de loi
dont l'objectif est louable et que nous
partageons tout ce qui est de lutter
contre la précarité alimentaire des
étudiants est évidemment le texte met en
avant un certain nombre d'insuffisances
et de difficultés cela a été souligné
la première celle
certains étudiants de 20 d'avoir accès à
un crous à une restauration collective
de fait tout simplement de leur
situation géographique
la deuxième c'est des plages d'ouverture
qui parfois ne conviennent pas des files
d'attentes qui peuvent aussi parfois
dissuader les étudiants et
vos modes de consommation c'est vrai que
le monde change et qu'il ya parfois une
demande de flexibilité aussi donc cette
proposition de loi pointe utilement des
manques et des besoins
pour autant notre groupe ne partage pas
entièrement la solution qui est proposé
cela a été dit d'abord parce qu' il
existe un service public qui sont les
crous qu'il faut conforter qu'il faut
renforcer et non pas fragiliser ils ont
d'ailleurs joué un rôle essentiel pour
la mise en place des repas un euro 2
repas 1 euro par jour
d'abord pour les boursiers et puis
ensuite pour tout le monde et donc il
faut aussi souligner leur rôle ils ont
par ailleurs cela a été aussi rappelé un
rôle important de socialisation de
rencontre de lieux de vie et donc c'est
ce type de d'endroits que nous voulons
bien sûr plutôt conforté que d'autres
types de restauration
et puis les émetteurs d'ailleurs de
tickets restaurants classiques nous ont
fait remarquer qu'il pouvait le faire et
qu'il l'avait fait à la demande de votre
ministère madame la ministre
en 2020 ils ont été distribué des
tickets restaurant à des étudiants en
détresse sociale aux plus grands à ceux
qui étaient en plus grande difficulté et
cela s'est bien passé il ya eu un
opérateur notamment qu'il a fait je
crois qu'il faut également le rappeler
enfin mais c'est pas un obstacle
dirimant 1 les deux grandes
organisations syndicales ne sont pas
très favorable à ce dispositif notamment
l'unef et la fage trop se veut pas dire
qu'il faut prendre pour argent comptant
la position des syndicats de manière
générale mais enfin parfois on dit qu'il
faut aussi s'appuyer sur les corps
intermédiaires donc je pense que les
deux sont sont justes et fo ni les
balayer d'un revers de main ni forcément
se coller à leurs positions c'est vrai
que
ces organisations ainsi sur le fait
qu'il faut plutôt aller dans l'effort
qui a déjà été lancée d'amélioration de
la qualité de la restauration cas-là
collective et il faudrait pas que ce
dispositions viennent remettre en cause
le mouvement qui préexistait et qui
plutôt un mouvement qui consiste à
renforcer à la fois la dimension que
collectives et la dimension qualitative
de la restauration universitaire donc ce
sont évidemment des raisons qui plaident
pour que le groupe ne puissent voter le
texte
reconnaissons quand même que la
commission a modifié substantiellement
le dispositif est qu'il apparaît comme
beaucoup plus ciblées autant le premier
la première version était faire poser un
certain nombre de grandes difficultés
autant sept nouveaux une nouvelle
version ciblent davantage évidemment les
étudiants qui ont qui auraient besoin de
ticket restaurant et puis coûterait
nécessairement moins chers du coup que
la première version que nous avions cela
étant dit il est évidemment difficile de
dire combien ça coûterait puisque ce
sont des tic est utilisé à la demande
peut-être faut-il travailler davantage à
la concertation à voir si on ne peut pas
encore affiner le dispositif il a déjà
été acheminés par rapport à ce que nous
avions eues en première enfin en tout
début
le rapporteur a fait un travail
intéressant avec l'auteur de la loi
pourra signer davantage de dispositifs
sans doute faut-il aller dans une étape
supplémentaire et dans cette attente le
groupe rdi s'abstiendra de façon
positive sur ce texte
merci beaucoup
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à annie billon pour le groupe
union centriste pour six minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur l'auteur de la proposition de
loi
mes chers collègues avec le logement les
dépenses d'alimentation constitue la
principale charge des étudiants en
fonction de leurs moyens financiers et
des charges fixes auquel ils ne peuvent
se soustraire parmi lesquelles figurent
notamment les frais de téléphonie
internet les achats de nourriture
essentielle par définition devienne une
variable d'ajustement qui se traduit
souvent par petites quantités mauvaise
qualité ou rien les conséquences
économiques et sociales de la crise
sanitaire que nous avons vécu n'ont en
rien arranger la situation des étudiants
elle a accentué les inégalités au sein
de cette population très hétérogène
affectant tout particulièrement des
étudiants ne bénéficiant pas d'un
soutien financier familial et ou
exerçant une activité rémunérée pour
subvenir à leurs besoins
les confinements successifs et la
fermeture des restaurants universités
hors terre les ans souvent privés d'un
repas équilibré par jour un quart des
étudiants dont les difficultés
financières se sont aggravées pendant le
confinement ont déclaré ne pas toujours
à avoir pu manger à leur faim
pour des raisons financières la hausse
de la fréquentation des épiceries
sociales et solidaires dans les campus
et l'affluence constatée lors des
distributions de colis alimentaires
organisée par l'essec les acteurs
associatifs témoigne de l'aggravation du
phénomène de précarité étudiante qui
préexistait à la crise le 25 janvier
dernier le gouvernement a mis en place
le repas 1 euro pour tous les étudiants
qu'ils soient boursiers ou non si nous
avons salué cette mesure
force est de constater qu'il existe un
peu à l'image des cartographies de
réseau téléphonique
des zones blanches une part trop
significatif d'étudiants est exclue de
ce dispositif
comme mon collègue pierre antoine lévy
auteurs de cette proposition de loi est
malheur appelé les étudiants peuvent
télétravailler mais ne peuvent pas télé
manger nous avons tous dans nos
circonscriptions des territoires sous
dotées en structures de restauration
universitaire en vendée par exemple la
faculté d'angers propose une formation
pour les el3 situé aux sables d'olonne
le crous le plus proche est à 30 km à la
roche-sur-yon rendant impossible toute
restauration étudiante
nous examinons donc aujourd'hui une
proposition de loi au service de ces
derniers visant à améliorer leurs
conditions d'accès à une restauration au
tarif étudiant comment en dupliquant un
dispositif social accessible aux
salariés en créant un ticket restaurant
à destination et étudiants qui leur
permettra d'accéder à une offre de
restauration de proximité à moindre coût
cette idée n'est pas nouvelle
mon collègue jeunes disons le le
rapporteur jean hingray la défendent est
déjà sur les bancs de l'université
avant de l'emporter sur les fauteuils de
notre assemblée
cette idée n'est pas nouvelle mais au
regard des conséquences de la crise
sanitaire
elle devient urgente ce ticket
restaurant permettra un élargissement du
cadre de la restauration étudiante à la
fois géographique et temporelle de
nombreux crous n'ouvre que sur la pause
méridienne et seulement quelques mois
dans l'année
elle permettra également plus de
souplesse aux étudiants qui pourront
utiliser ces tickets resto au restaurant
ou pour faire leurs courses et cuisiner
chez eux
l'amendement proposé par le rapporteur
durant l'examen en commission est que
nous avons adoptée a permis de réajuster
le dispositif en se concentrant
uniquement sur les étudiants éloignés
de toute structure je ne doute pas que
les étudiants qui assistent à cette
séance aujourd'hui partageront cet avis
cette clarification permet de contrer
les abus éventuels
elle s'inscrit dans une démarche
d'offres complémentaires et non
concurrentielle avec le réseau des
oeuvres universitaires et scolaires
évitant ainsi tout risque de
déstabilisation de ce dernier pour
conclure je souhaite saluer notre
collègue pierre antoine lévy auteurs de
cette proposition de loi
ainsi que le rapporteur jean à gré pour
leurs travaux précis et efficace au
service de l'amélioration des conditions
de vie de nos étudiants lourdement
impacté par la crise sanitaire est trop
souvent oublié ces derniers mois le
groupe union centriste
votre a unanimement cette proposition de
loi madame la ministre
entendez cet appel des étudiants éloigné
des sites
ils sont là aujourd'hui en tribunes je
les salue donc elle peut propres y
prospérer rapidement alors saisissez
vous de ce texte je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues la parole est
désormais à stéphane pieds noirs ont
cinq minutes pour le groupe l'est
républicain qui sera le dernier 1/4
monroe
c'est le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la détresse dans
laquelle se trouve plongée bon nombre
d'étudiants depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire que nous traversons s'est
singulièrement illustré par les images
de longues files d'attentes occasionnés
par la distribution de repas gratuits
ce phénomène fait largement conjoncturel
a mis en exergue les difficultés
matérielles rencontrées par les
étudiants dont la vie est loin d'être un
long fleuve tranquille se nourrir au
même titre que seloger ressemblent pour
certains un véritable parcours du
combattant dans lequel on cherche
davantage des mesures palliatives qu'un
confort idéal une solution dans laquelle
on se satisfait de conditions juste
acceptable pour poursuivre ses études à
travers la proposition de loi déposée au
sénat par pierre antoine lévy et à
l'assemblée nationale par ma collègue du
maine et loire ain lambelin il s'agit de
prendre en considération la prix qu'est
la précarité alimentaire dont souffrent
certains étudiants et pour les stomp est
de proposer une mesure de tickets
restaurants dont chacun connaît le
fonctionnement pour les salariés du
secteur privé
alors comment adapter un tel dispositif
au public estudiantin
la question n'est pas si simple et je
veux saluer le travail du rapporteur
jean à gré qui tout au long de ces
auditions des auditions qui l'a mené à
bien mesurer les écueils les difficultés
d'application et les impacts de cette
mesure
en premier lieu une instauration
généralisé pour tous les étudiants quel
que soit le franc le campus fréquenté
comporté à mon sens un potentiel risque
de déstabilisation du réseau des crous
qui rappelons le ont la charge à la fois
des restaurants et des résidences
universitaires
mon dernier rapport budgétaire mettait
en lumière les pertes financières des
cros qui sont concentrés sur la partie
restauration
de plus de nouvelles exigences liées par
exemple à la loi et câline en matière
d'approvisionnement locaux en aliments
bio
engendré un surcoût non négligeable pour
ces crous il me semble par conséquent
délicat de les solliciter davantage sans
une augmentation de la subvention pour
charges de service public et nous
pourrons avoir ce débat lors du prochain
examen du plf cependant il reste les
fameuses zones blanches évoquée par le
rapporteur tout à l'heure c'est à dire
pour l'essentiel les antennes
universitaires non pourvus de restaurant
universitaire où chacun doit se
débrouiller pour accéder à une
alimentation un tarif raisonnable et si
possible équilibré je félicite le
rapporteur pour avoir trouvé via un
amendement largement adopté en
commission de la culture une réécriture
de l'article 1er qui vise une judicieuse
territorialisation de la mesure
le décret d'application devra évidemment
préciser les modalités de mise en oeuvre
de ce ticket restaurant étudiants
notamment son périmètre et son usage
il subsiste toutefois semble-t-il
quelques interrogations voire certains
griefs contre cette initiative
législative
c'est bien connu quand on veut se
débarrasser de son chien on dit qu'il a
la rage
j'estime par exemple que le coût de la
mesure est largement surévalué la
subvention envisager de 3h30 par up ne
saurait être multiplié par le nombre
d'étudiants quasiment 2 millions 8 et le
nombre de repas que compte une année
universitaire d'une part la
territorialisation évoqué précédemment
réduit considérablement
l'assiette si je puis dire d'autre part
les habitudes des étudiants sont
diverses et une étude montre même que
moins d'un étudiant sur deux fréquentent
les restaurants universitaires
de plus rappelons que comme les autres
salariés pour les du secteur privé il
s'agit d'une opportunité que chaque
étudiant aura la possibilité ou non
d'exercer à sa guise et non bien
évidemment de manière systématique et
puis il ya le procès d'une faveur à
destination des chaînes de restauration
rapide considérant que chaque étudiant
muni de son ticket restaurant du mois
qui se précipitera jour après jour pour
acheter avaler son hamburger favoris
sans autres considérations diététique
curieusement je n'ai pas beaucoup
entendu
que ces tickets pourrait aussi être
employée chez des restaurateurs qui
rappelons le souffre depuis maintenant
18 mois
je voudrais rappeler que nous évoquons
de jeunes adultes régulièrement sens
habite sensibiliser à la problématique
de l'alimentation et de ses conséquences
sur leur santé des jeunes gens dotés me
semble-t-il d'une certaine capacité à
avoir une attitude responsable
si je reprends cet argument faudrait-il
envisager que toute mesure d' aides
sociales des allocations logement au rsa
en passant par les indemnités chômage
devrait être accompagné d'un mode
d'emploi d'un règlement pour son usage
voire pourquoi pas d'un conseiller
délivrant les autorisations de
décaissement je ne souscris évidemment
pas à cette vision de mise sous tutelle
pour les raisons que j'ai évoquées les
sénateurs du groupe
les républicains ont choisi de faire
confiance à ce dispositif novateur de
faire confiance aux étudiants pour son
usage et par conséquent ils voteront
pour l'adoption de ce texte journal
[Applaudissements]
il ya un cher collègue la discussion
générale est close nous allons passer à
l'examen du texte de la commission
il ya un premier amendement sur
l'article 1er présenté par madame von
aig mon numéro un monsieur le président
mais mes chers collègues la mise en
place d'un ticket restaurant
universitaire 20ème restreint au
bénéfice des seuls étudiants éloignés
des centres universitaires va permettre
à l'initiative privée de se substituer
partiellement au service public de
restauration universitaire tout en ayant
néanmoins recours à des financements
publics la mise en place de ce ticket
risque d'entraîner une diminution de la
fréquentation des restos u et donc une
baisse de leurs moyens qui sera lourde
de conséquences en terme social et de
pérennité de leurs réseaux ce dispositif
est en outre très flou quant aux
financeurs et à leurs participations
respectives dans le dispositif
il ne présente aucune garantie
d'exigence de qualité nutritive ça a été
dit une des repas qui seront accessibles
grâce aux tic et celui ci ne sera
vraisemblablement pas accessible aux
étudiants les plus précaires puisqu'il
apparaît à la lecture de l'exposé des
motifs de la proposition de loi qu'une
part non négligeable restera à la charge
des destinataires de ce ticket il aurait
été préférable de rediriger les fonds
publics prévus pour financer ce ticket
resto u vers le renforcement des aides
sociales et nous demandons donc la
suppression de cet article
merci chers collègues y at il des
demandes d'explications de vote sur cet
amendement
pardon d'abord l'avis du rapporteur
avant de
des explications beauté excusez moi très
bien merci monsieur le président madame
la sénatrice en guerre somine un avis
défavorable naturellement et si je puis
me permettre suite à votre intervention
à la tribune
j'aurais préféré au lieu de cet
amendement de suppression comme vous
l'avez regretter et à quelques instants
en amendement sur la mise en place d'un
critère social lors de nos échanges et
débats en audition au puy en commission
si vous tenir à ce critère nous aurions
pu être naturellement à l'écouté
favorable à cette proposition qui n'est
malheureusement pas arrivé à sur la
table de notre ouvrage donc un avis
défavorable
madame la ministre ou votre avis merci à
son président monsieur appelons la
commission sera porteur mesdames et
sénatrices et sénateurs d'abord je
voulais profiter de cette opportunité
pour remercier le sénat sur tous les
bancs pour le soutien et l'hommage
appuyé au cnous au crous à ses
personnels auxquels bien sûr je
m'associe je pense qu'ils seront très
sensibles à la reconnaissance de ce rôle
essentiel qu'ils ont joué auprès de noé
fusion je voulais aussi une fois de plus
remercier l'auteur du texte le
rapporteur la commission pour avoir mis
un coup de projecteur sur ce sujet qui
est bien réel
je salue et comme toujours la très
grande qualité des débats c'est pourquoi
ce sera un avis de sagesse du
gouvernement il ya merci donc un avis
défavorable de la commission un avis de
sagesse du gouvernement yat-il des
demandes d'explications de vote sur cet
amendement de suppression
non nous avons passé aux voix qui est
pauvre
votre goût
de cela
qui est qui et contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté bien nous allons passer
donc au vote de l'article 1er qui est
pauvre qui est contre 6 s'abstient il
est adopté l'article 2 est supprimé
article 3 il s'agissait d'un amendement
de coordination il n'a plus sa raison
d'être donc je le retire donc il est
retiré donc je soumets ou voix l'article
3 qui est pour et contre qui s'abstient
bien je vais mettre aux voix donc
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi il
ya t'il des demandes d'explications de
vote
je n'en vois pas je pense qu'elles ont
été donnés dans la discussion générale
je vais donc mettre aux voix l'ensemble
de la proposition de loi visant à créer
un ticket restaurant étudiants qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient la
proposition de loi est donc être adoptés
[Musique]